hi
[Music]
when we get to Babel to access
full transportation, it is very difficult
because I am also a disabled person in
the recipe video, I want to give something to
my friends from the problems we are
facing regarding transportation,
my name is Triono as founder
and CEO of Didi, of course,
transport  we are unique, one culprit is
disabled, all of that goes to and we prioritize
services for friends with
disabilities.
Hi, maybe if we count, we have
delivered from 2015 v2017. Thousands of
people with special needs
we have managed to mobilize, even
friends whose terms are in
remote areas.  mobilization
identification of passengers is number one
eel aha time, place and
needs we have to provide,
we have two types of motorbikes, yes, one is
single ship only for
seats, the other is for the military for wheelchairs
Hi
before us these Divas walked they
couldn't move, finally got depressed
first  we think simple can
n  where do they go and then go home
again, we never imagined the
impact would be this big so it's not
that great, we're good
hi
hu hu